in my book captive ology a captivation
trigger is a psychological trigger that
that forces us to pay attention to
something in some way they are either
subconscious or conscious triggers that
make us turn our heads Beyonce is a
different than all other artists in the
fact that she's been so good at
capturing attention over the long term
and so Beyonce's real secret is that
she's built this relationship with her
audience what she used as a trigger I
call the acknowledgement trigger and
what she's done is make it so that when
people think about her they associate
things like beauty and in like a level
higher kind of like this kind of thing
you want to be and so one of the things
I learned about celebrity in celebrity
culture is that when you pay attention
to celebrity it's kind of a reflection
of who you are being a fan of a Beyonce
says something about you versus being a
fan of say one direction or Justin
Bieber or or Jennifer Lawrence and so
beyonce has the beyhive and that's the
name of her fans and she really done a
great job of acknowledging her fans and
getting to know them and creating
amazing work for them and interacting
with them and so what happens when she
drops an album without any kind of
marketing beforehand is that it becomes
platinum because one it was completely
different because you're not supposed to
drop an album and it's not supposed to
go immediately platinum because of that
and two it's because they know her name
she's taken years to build her name and
her brand and done all the things she
needed to do there's a certain point
where the more you do that the more your
name's recognized and the more power the
more power and the intention you can
capture that's where why long-term brand
building really matters beyonce has done
that for years as a result she can just
drop an album and it'll get attention
Mark Zuckerberg does use the
acknowledgement trigger for Facebook but
in a different way we go to Facebook
because we find acknowledgment and
validation from others on Facebook think
about when you post a status update
you're trying to figure out you know
what thing what witty thing to say
what cute picture you can put on and if
suddenly you get a hundred likes on your
facebook status you feel a sense of joy
because that means you were clever you
were witty or your friends just like you
and this is the sense of validation that
we come back to social networks for I
still even I understand it and I know
this stuff but I still feel joy if like
one of my tweets gets a hundred retweets
or if my Instagram post gets fifty likes
that sense is a sense of acknowledgement
we keep coming back to it because
validation and acknowledgement is a
fundamental human need we need to we
feel the need to pay attention to the
things that pay attention to us and
that's why Mark Zuckerberg and Facebook
have captured so much attention there
are two things I think when I think Tom
Hanks the first is that he's not trying
to get attention for himself and so one
big lesson to learn from all the Masters
of attention is that they don't try to
get attention necessarily for themselves
but for their projects their passions
and ideas you don't see Tom Hanks on
every TV show all the time same with
like Will Smith and such they only come
out when they have something really
important to promote or a cause that
they want to talk about that works
really well because they're not over
exposing themselves to their audience
and it makes it very clear it's not
about them it's about the stuff that
they're doing and people really
appreciate that and Tom Hanks too just
has this projection of being a very nice
and lovable guy and in fact there's a
scientific term for the kind of feelings
we have for someone like Tom Hanks and
it's called the parasocial relationship
which is our capability to feel like we
have a two-way relationship with a
celebrity or a brand or an icon even
though Tom Hanks will never meet us or
ever really get to know us we feel like
we know him and he's been the master
building that because of the kind things
he's done and because of his kind nature
and the stories we hear about him and
that is a form of attention that lasts
forever
you